foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're here we're clear
got a fun guest today Jim Norton I hope
the weather is crazy out today right
yeah I want to come in and just do bits
yeah right how about that trans shooter
the guy the guy in the elevator the
other day I was with someone she goes so
I'm going to California and he goes
you're going now just so the weather's
going nice
you know when it rains like oh you
brought it with you I guess you brought
it with you I'm like no I didn't bring
anything I'll actually agree with them
though and go with the bit and go yeah
more
keep it coming
that's uh that's a lot of peeves this
week I have a lot of peeves oh yeah a
lot of uh annoying you know what annoyed
me recently is uh pers people that don't
put their dogs on leashes really annoy
me there's a there's a hallway and
they're just running through the hallway
what yeah and then they're just like
come here come here and the dog doesn't
come and you're like it's a get a leash
yeah yeah but then there's a problem
with the leash guy who stretched out the
leech all over the sidewalks it's a
domination thing it's one of those
things they want to show you the control
they have over their animals so what
happens is I hate when the elevator
opens and then they take the leash off
and they let it run down the hall yes
it's like wow this [__] Beastmaster
yeah it is kind of annoying I understand
that's true yeah it sucks now they're
having a big problem with dogs are
[__] on planes because they'll have
like multiple service dogs now so
there's all these videos online like
Tick Tock there's just dogs people
stepping dog [__] in the aisle of a
Southwest flight damn it's out of
control didn't they stop allowing all
those like animals on didn't they say
like no no more or we're only going to
allow certain service animals and no
more Comfort dogs I think you get the
paperwork you're good to go I think
anyone can bring a dog on I remember the
whole United thing remember they were
having a bad week
imagine being the guy who's waiting to
get off your connecting flight and
there's a 13 year old holding her
[__] dead
and you're like I don't want to be a
[__] here but I'm going to [__]
fight in 15 minutes
I guess I only have one uh checked bag
now
I do kind of like that guy though
because he's like I feel bad about the
dog so I'll put it up here that's pretty
considerate I mean it's not for the dog
no it wasn't he didn't do it no he
didn't no they made him do it no one
wants to voluntarily put their dog in
the oven Oh I thought he was a nice guy
no it was the flight attendant I guess
the dog was too big for under and this
is what like great owners they were they
did it was like a two and a half hour
flight and they didn't notice that the
dog wasn't making any noise like for two
hours they didn't check on the [__]
dog for over two hours yeah and they got
like a a sad slash hilarious surprise
the dog was screaming they just had
noise canceling the whole time on the
computer yeah that's that whimper hate a
dog whimper you wouldn't think those are
airtight though would you like I would
think that you could get air in there
totally but maybe a bump jerked him
right something maybe the poor little
guy was just so frightened his heart
quit hopefully
yeah you've lost every dog lover in the
first three minutes yeah yeah well keep
off the flights God damn it yeah but my
ex had a Chihuahua and she was a great
girl and she was a fun lady but that dog
was a nightmare was hell everybody hated
the dog we didn't have the heart to tell
her you got brain cancer eventually we
all had a party sure you're gonna go the
other way with that where you're like uh
but the the dog was all right
it's great gal yeah the dog was fun but
uh
she uh she would drug it with Benadryl
to get it on a flight because it was
just so yappy and it was the best it was
the best dog when it was on Benadryl
sure but otherwise it was hell I imagine
the brain cancer mellowed it yeah
a lot you don't typically see more
hyperactivity there's a [__] lump in
the head poor little guy how long did he
last after they got the terrible
prognosis very a couple months but he
would do a thing where he was [__]
diarrhea his whole body was all [__]
up but he was [__] next to the pee pad
like used to [__] on it and then he
would [__] next to it because of the
brain cancer and it just made you wanted
to go come on die already yeah yeah
that's that's almost like an angry Thing
by the dog like he knows the P yeah he's
there and he's like I'm gonna [__] on
the rug anyway to tell you something's
wrong exactly exactly cats would do that
too I had a cat years ago I had three
roommates in Brooklyn and uh I I was on
the road every weekend so I couldn't I
could every time I would leave the cat
would just be like like now meow and I'd
be like I gotta work right and then at a
certain point you're just like all right
well I gotta get rid of it every time I
get the cat would just piss on someone
else's [__] yeah so now I'm getting home
and they're like your cat peed on my
back and I have to be like all right how
much was the bag at a certain point I
was like I gotta get rid of the cat that
was your cat yeah oh it was my friend's
sister is Dan Hall who bartends at the
seller it was his sister's cat and she
asked me to watch the cat for a week and
I was like all right I could watch a cat
for a week and then she just moved so
I'm just stuck with the cat oh damn yeah
but then the cat was pretty cool until
this [__] happened right I had two I
never had pets I had cats growing up and
I I'm so stupid I was five when I got a
Manx cat with the tail oh yeah and I
named him Susan because I didn't know it
was a guy so I I named you always were
trying to do it yeah believe me I've
made these mistakes many times I named
him uh Susan and like oh it's a boy so I
called him John and then the other cat
was I named William we found her outside
but it was a female twice I made the
mistake of naming them opposite gender
names they're both dead now um the only
animals ever had yeah yeah but you I
have a cat now named Greg so I'm
continuing the the human name isn't it
weird like a weird I don't know why I
was a kid though when you're a kid you
don't have a [__] name nothing of
course not so that makes sense but I'll
tell you this I have a cat and people
come over and they go I don't know how
you do it the litter box the scratching
but they have kids and I'm like you have
[__] up kids that you know fall off
the stairs or cry or [__] themselves
like you're gonna give me [__] when you
got a kid yeah at least I can back over
this thing in the driveway when it
annoys me you have to tolerate it until
it goes to college it's also weird to
say you know like Susan has cancer and
you're like oh my God you're like it's
my cat
that's all right I mean you say cookie
has cancer like cookies yeah Magic
Johnson's upset
what's up with this girlfriend of yours
Susan's an amazing name for a cat isn't
it yeah it is an adult but it's such a
plain [__] name that a boy would want to
call his cat Susan I don't know why that
was a little [__] fruit
well you grew up in New Jersey huh the
suburbs yeah yeah I was it was all
teenage angst you know that [__]
melodrama of the you know [__]
cutting yourself like [__] I like the
devil you know I was like an emo douche
before it was popular I remember it I
was on the uh the road once and
uh actually I wasn't this wasn't even I
was like it must have been like a family
thing I was in a hotel room with my
brother I was very young I remember
watching I think it was Monster Rain
you're special oh it was just on TV and
my brother didn't know who you were so
his intro to you was the [__] Monster
Rain bit and I hope you and your brother
made eye contact alone in the bedroom to
realize things should happen but it's
like when you like don't know what to
expect he turned me was like this guy's
really funny hey
all right Monster Rain yeah I still I
saw that porch whenever I'm gonna do the
stress Factory I go back to that
apartment complex because I always think
something else happened there because
I'm so [__] up I'm like something else
happened but I still look at that
Porsche that we used to crawl under it's
now made of wood I think it used to be
metal and then there's a basement window
under it and I kind of vaguely remember
being in that basement and I'm like it's
probably not good whatever it was right
right wow was it was it uh did you you
were probably dying to get out trying to
get to the city
um you know how it is man I lived at my
parents until I was 30. whoa obviously
that's why I guess I just get hookers
and I would park in my parents driveway
and put up the sun thing that blocks the
sun oh yeah that would get blown in the
driveway uh I would back into the uh the
thing so I couldn't take them in the
house yeah of course I like living at
home but it was time to move out I moved
them with Florentine and uh well I think
it was 90. is this one he had long hair
I I don't know if he was still jamming
Jim he used to be jamming Gym Howard
Stern named him jam and Jim The Rock and
Roll comedian so when I met him he was
jamming Jim and I [__] hated him I
was like who is this ass he had on like
snakeskin boots
but he wanted to get me my first paid
gig in in 1991 so Jim has been there
since like day one today he's the first
comic I ever did a weekend with and he
was [__] awesome isn't he great he's
such a great guy yeah no one's ever bad
mouth Florentine like no one thinks
florentine's a dick no no no no and he
gets laid apparently women find him
attractive which I find surprising yeah
I know I knew him in his Heyday he used
to make us like he would walk by a woman
and he would go tell me if she gives me
a cheek peek and he wasn't being ironic
he wanted to see if the girl looked at
his ass yeah if she looked at his ass he
knew she was interested and I watched it
many times and it would work I mean
Florentine but had great numbers oh yeah
he was banging Robin Quivers for a while
yes he did date her I don't know how
long it's insane I mean that's like a
high profile black lady yes well well
done yeah I don't know how long it
lasted or or exactly what broke it up I
don't think I ever asked Jim about Robin
I probably should have yeah and I know
she's a size queen so obviously he's
doing all right he's big balls as long
as he's big balls like he's he's all
ball he used to like the show and
scrotum off his dick he called it a baby
hippity hop because the [__] the
balls were big and the dick was like
fine okay it was all ball Ari's like
that too he's all bald he's having huge
balls is not doing your dick any favors
it's like having huge quads yeah but you
get the package in the pants because the
balls help the balls so that's a decent
at least you get them in the door so if
it's like an Anthony Weiner underwear
pick it's exactly yeah yeah bring your
own infant of course
he didn't even have a great bulge
wieners uh I've seen his dick uh I've
actually got leaves and Dick it was fine
I mean it was like dumb Brett Favre's
dick he aims it was the worst dick
picture ever Brett Favre aimed his dick
down with his [__] shoes yeah uh he
was wearing like those those Beach shoes
yeah yeah
I believe so yeah and he is pretty thick
I thought it was wide I found it to be
remarkably unimpressive for a future
Hall of Famer damn yeah okay I don't
know if it's out there but I've seen the
dick pic and it was just he was like
holding it to make it like tilting it at
a weird angle and I was like that's a
bad pick man oh no well he's older so
he's not he's not hip to the dick pic
world
yeah he's in a lot of trouble isn't he
didn't he do some [__] and well he's
suing Pat McAfee there's this weird back
and forth where he was involved with
some type of it had something to do with
his kids a tennis court a volleyball
thing for their school and then there
was allegations that the [__] funds
got diverted
for was it like welfare or some social
services interesting and they said that
Brett knew about it I don't know the
details uh obviously by the way I'm
talking about it but then McAfee said
something that I guess he thought was
actionable and he's suing Pat McAfee
whoa and somebody else uh but I don't
know any more details about that uh than
that it's a tough diet Colin Quinn said
it best you can get a lot of trouble
what you say and all we do is talk now
into microphones yeah where we used to
not do this we do it all day every day
and now you get more trouble just saying
crazy [__] and we're just giving it out
there and the more we talk the less
we're actually informed we're just yeah
all the time true not great well no one
lit nobody wants to listen to anybody it
really is it's like when you're just
waiting all right here's my chance to
make a point that's why I don't listen
to any of it I I listen to none of it I
can't you don't listen to the backlash
or you don't listen to anything people I
don't check at mentions because I'm I'm
I just don't I don't give a [__] about
the comments you know I hate when people
go read your comments [__] you like
create because you want to create
something not because commenters are you
know we have enough feedback from live
audiences completely agree like it's
like I get enough attention like it was
bothering me that like how much uh how
much complete validation do you need I
was just made me sick the way I was so I
just stopped and you dwell on it
somebody's like hey your earlobes aren't
connected I'm like I know but now I'm in
the shower going out of the earlobes you
know and it doesn't do anything someone
could say that yeah take the earlobe
thing yeah the earlobe thing would be a
home run
[__] yeah yeah but like I also think
about that I Mark checks every comment
Mark reads a lot of comments and I think
about like how many specials you must
have put out where there was no comments
like HBO
right all these days you know Comedy
Central all these specials and then uh
and Netflix and then now you know the
specials that pop for Mark and myself
were on YouTube it's just all comments
right right and it's okay to let people
make them but I I find that reading them
like I I know what I do on stage so like
I can tell if it worked or Not by the
reaction true we're not doing things in
a vacuum and I think it was just
unhealthy for me like I just kept
obsessing over it and I was like what
are you doing like who the [__] even if
these people like you that was it was
like I don't like myself
just with the neediness of it annoyed me
yeah and I got out of the habit of doing
it and we're driving the ship we got to
remember that like we'll have no guest
on and we'll have a guess and be like
yeah I guess [__] the guests or I like
it better with no guests or whatever and
you're like oh maybe we should do that
but then you go no we're doing our show
stop telling us what to do yeah you have
on who you want to have on and you know
you know what's funny you know it's not
fun you know yeah that's what I try to
uh live by it's hard though I mean it's
really hard people will insult me in my
at mentions well the question is you've
seen both sides of this comedy industry
where it was like all audience no
internet traveling on the road doing
gigs you had your radio show but now
it's just all internet it feels like it
is all internet but I've been getting
bashed I mean I'm kind of immune to
feeling bashed online I just don't care
because it's been happening for over 20
years like yeah first time I read
negative [__] about myself
was right after 9 11. I was I did some
joke on the radio and people like that's
[__] too soon I remember reading it
like one of those Message Board yeah
things so you get used to it after a
while you just become numb to the fact
that no matter what you do people are
going to be [__] and I guess do you
remember the Joker no I don't even
remember it was it might have been it
was on the air it was a radio thing
um so it was just you know made fun of
something but I remember on 911 oh sorry
I remember I called into open Anthony
because we couldn't get into the city
um I remember calling in as like the
naval planes were circling and I wanted
to do a joke I remember because I used
to always plug it inappropriate times
but I was like I remember almost
plugging gigs but I'm like ah don't I
even in that moment I'm like this would
be a bad don't even don't do it yeah
yeah yeah you can smell smoke you should
probably not plug but the question is
have we gotten easily offended or is it
just easier to get the offended out
there in public you know because like uh
Seth MacFarlane said when he started
Family Guy he would get bags of hate
meal like garbage bags and garden they
would just throw them in the dumpster
but now both they get read online and
they they put and then they catch and
everybody goes yes you are homophobic it
must be weirdly satisfied deleting an
email doesn't feel great
in the dumpster literally and then light
it on fire knowing they haven't been
hurt yes the best that's why I don't
block I mute keep talking yeah
and somebody had to write down and fold
it and lick it and put a stamp on it and
send it and we don't even read it but
Mark and I talk about this all the time
like how I don't I'm not one of those
comics who's like people are easily
offended now I don't care most crowds
are pretty good for the most part still
sure but uh your generation was so much
tougher at the table just hanging out
like your generation of you Colin you
know Bobby Patrice Burr Nick yeah but
you also at that time it was different
because we were dealing with political
correctness from like 1990 like you know
what I mean like so we had it too it was
just a different it just layers up we're
levels up every few years it gets
exponentially worse like you know what I
mean like this beauty of this like all
these people now these woke people they
are committing a sin somehow that
they're not aware of as a sin but people
who are being born now in 15 years will
tell them what their sin is yeah so
that's the only thing that whole I hold
on to is all these little [__] uh
that's a problem oh are you gonna
[__] get it in 15 years right because
you don't know the sin you're committing
is a sin right now yeah I actually saw
someone I follow on Twitter this uh this
political guy Matt Welch post uh
yesterday this woman was getting torn
apart online I just saw him quote tweet
it and he wrote remember when you called
me a transpho oh like this isn't fun oh
it wasn't like hateful it's just kind of
like Matt welshower Walsh Welch oh I
don't know he's like a he has a podcast
uh he's on Bill Marshall oh okay but
yeah welcome to the party get in line
this is this is what you guys do it
sucks right it's yeah it's all endless
so it's like you may as well chill out
yeah you may as well ignore it I get
called a transphob like uh it was some
Caitlyn Jenner joke I had done I don't
remember what it was something about
yeah I was shocked it was something
about in politics and tying in with
being one thing and not the other
um and people [__] they were a few is
this the hilly you want to die on and
like you're transphobic it's just you
know kids [__] you Ariel get called a
Nazi and you're like look at his face I
know come on I know he's not he's a
propaganda poster
exactly but the way bugs me the most is
I get it there's stupid people they're
angry they want clicks but when you go
hey I'm Jewish they go ah they don't
care they don't care but you should go
oh [__] I didn't know that my bad Nazi
doesn't make sense take it back because
it's not about the point it's about
being angry and it's like it's almost
like if somebody tells you and corrects
you and then you go oh then you can't be
angry like it's all a lie just to excuse
being angry it feels right oh that's a
good point you know so people don't want
to not be angry yeah do you think is
there any party that satisfied these
people that come after you and then find
out that you were with a trans person or
like maybe or do you think that makes no
difference to them um I mean if it was
if it was a trans person but I put quite
a few through college
but no I I don't ever think of it like
that like if they don't know they don't
know like I don't care because again
it's never about I don't even think
they're being legitimate when they
accuse me of it so me not being
transform I don't doesn't mean anything
because their accusation is a lie so I
don't care and I don't care even if they
mean it really go ahead I don't you know
trust me you know talk to my [__] uh
talk to my tonsils they'll tell you the
truth
but as Comics I feel like we want to be
accurate we want to be right about
everything so when they're not right you
want you're like wait why aren't you
ashamed of being incredibly inaccurate
because we deal with hecklers like if a
guy heckles you it's right there you
deal with it it's addressed yeah you he
knows you know what he said they all
know it's almost like you have the judge
and the jury in the same way yes but you
don't have that online because you know
no but that thing you said it's too
diluted but in a club it's you suck and
then you Hammer them yeah oh it's so
satisfying it's literally a town hall
meeting where you get Applause after
every Interruption yes [__] great
yeah because you're always gonna win oh
yeah if you don't win you can yeah I
mean you have a microphone yeah you
should I've gone sometimes you go too
hard yeah you lose yeah hey you [__] and
they're like whoa easy yeah oh it's a
kid walking through to the bed
but then you can kind of [__] on
yourself for going too hard there's
still ways to save it and that's true
and uh you're always gonna you're always
gonna come off better than them yeah
yeah I mean early on I definitely lost
yes oh early on I remember some of those
where you're like oh I I saw a legendary
one it wasn't me but I was at a show and
a comic was on stage doing a fat joke
and a guy in the front row was like
crazy obese like huge and he goes hey
enough with the fat stuff and he goes
sir relax you're gonna die in a year
anyway and he the whole crowd turned on
the guy stood up it got ugly and uh I
was like all right noted don't do that
yeah hopefully he was right though
you guys stood up and he was like oh
yeah he's reading the obituaries for the
next 12 months I was crying I lost once
I don't remember what the guy said it
was probably 1991 or it's like my first
two years of doing stand-up and I was
getting hammered by this guy in Wildwood
New Jersey and he was [__] Relentless
he was funny so afterwards I talked to
him and he was actually a cool guy yeah
sorry about that and his job was he was
a dunk tank clown oh my so he was used
to [__] just ripping people
and he smashed me pretty good I lost
that one with the one I can remember
losing you think a dunk tank clown that
guy has never heard the sentence he won
right he lost in life but see the sad
thing now is I hear that story I'm like
that'd be a great clip because we're so
[__] obsessed with the clips yeah but
you guys you guys are what you're doing
is so good because you're putting out
like funny original [__] that's like it
it gets people to people to come see you
you don't rely on the business like it's
great that's true you're not burning
material or the way you do it where you
do so much topical stuff I mean I love
following you with the seller or
following Colin at the seller because
you guys always have new topical [__]
yeah I'm always like curious I'm like oh
what's your angle going to be on uh
Dylan Mulvaney on the Bud Light thing
what's your angle going to be on this
story like I'm just I know you're gonna
have something yeah the Dylan Mulvaney
thing has been a tough sell you know
nobody wants to hear well it's the first
time I ever jerked off to a beer can
well that that topic is so uh
nerve-wracking that even if you're
positive they're like well I don't know
is he being facetious what's going on
here yeah I put up a clip about it and
it's like I I'm sure that people are
split on it I'm sure some people think
like oh just when they get when they
give you a series but no but what you
really need to see yeah no I don't know
I just don't care I'm making fun of
something I'm joking about something I
don't care if you don't like it don't
what do I tell you right right there's
no final conclusion we're gonna have
when we walk away yeah gentlemen who
understand each other I did a joke you
don't like it that's the end of it there
you go and I don't know why people are
this angry I get it it's a weird Choice
obviously it's a controversial to people
I don't know I feel like a lot of people
are Kid Rock shooting [__] with a
machine gun he's shooting Bud Light cam
like that'll show him I'll tell you that
guy exactly he doesn't really that
doesn't [__] around I mean he doesn't
like a beer can he shoots it get out of
his way you know yeah of course he
doesn't like trans people it looks like
[__] Fiona Apple
but it's a fake Rebellion it's a fake
thing from all these guys because like
it's simply an advertising thing Bud
Light has people who are probably just
mostly like these guys that are like a
certain type and people are like you
should know your core audience well yeah
dummy they want to expand their you know
what is a bunch of Bud Light fans get
together as a group it's out it's an
alcohol that they want to expand to
other people so they probably want young
trans people and they get this hot like
you know uh
um I should say yeah yeah yeah a hot uh
relevant relevant there you go I'm not
saying the hot is wrong but I'm just
that's just not my yeah um you know yeah
it's also a reminder that they have the
guns because when Chick-fil-A said they
were against gay marriage years ago
there were no there were no uh left-wing
people like see this chicken breast I'm
gonna [__] shoot it you know it's
true it's a reminder like this there's
different forms of protest yes yes
exactly there's boycott and picketing
and then this AK-47 I don't eat a
Chick-fil-A I don't like it and I don't
like the fact that they're against gay
people I just like [__] them but I'm not
going to tell anybody else not to eat
there I don't care who else goes there I
just I'm like yeah [__] them it's a good
product I don't feel a need I know
everybody loves it I should try it I
didn't love it but I don't feel the need
to put a bunch of [__] in front of a
lake and walk around and go hey it all
tastes pretty much the same to me so if
I'm Gonna Eat Fried Chicken I'll [__]
I'll go to the place I wasn't vocal
right we're against gay marriage but I
do think it's like this religious thing
they're all about religion Christianity
but what about the
groups overseas who don't like the gays
why don't people boycott that uh because
uh Christianity is is like the OG and
it's a safer one to boycott safer
because people aren't worried that
somebody who's Christian they might have
like an occasional abortion doctor
shooter I'm not saying they're all great
yeah but you're not worried that
Christians are going to run into your
place of business with an explosive so
people criticize what they feel safe is
that what Christianity is the safe one
to go after right other people feel like
they're going to be in danger going
after Jews are safe to wear like people
go after Jews too yeah but I think
Christians and Jews are the ones that
people feel like they can get away with
it but other religions are afraid will
respond violently and you could be
called xenophobic yeah I guess going
after a different race or skin color or
whatever yeah I guess so I mean I I
don't know why anybody I don't think it
fits their narrative maybe I think
that's another part of it yeah exactly I
want to ask you because I'm looking at
you and it's Norm and Bob Saga behind
you and I'm remembering that you did the
second two who are and one who should be
but I mean that was a you had a great
set in that roast that was a great roast
I remember uh
I mean Norm set was so amazing that was
the famous anti-comedy dorm speech or
yeah he kind of I mean was there a point
I watched that live I remember being
like what is he doing and then by the
end I was like this is amazing brilliant
yeah it was very funny the crowd was
kind of in and out on it but it was
still funny like I knew it was weird and
I had to address it but uh people
thought like he didn't get what Norm was
of course I [__] I'm doing stand-up
15 years at that point I got it it was
right right I enjoyed it but you had a
roast I'm not gonna stand up there and
just applaud and die I'm gonna make fun
of him and then you had a great line how
did you come up with that blueberries
line
um I just I have very very limited movie
taste and I would thank God something
[__] uh falls into the ungolden pond
right but he had a great comeback he had
a great comeback he had a great line and
we'd all love to watch Henry Fonda
picking blueberry I mean it was worth
holding the newspaper and he folded he
goes well who wouldn't want it I mean
he's such a [__] beast yeah he was
awesome and Saget was such a so I was
only on that road because Bob requested
me like uh I you know Comedy Central
never put me on any of that stuff but
Bob is like I want Jim on it and he was
a good dude man he was a really sweet
guy and I I you know he's one of those
guys I remember I sent a dirty text to a
girl about who used to jerk me off but I
accidentally sent it to him and uh that
became like this great bonding moment
between us because for years we laughed
about it but I sent him something about
was like a code like hey I think I
really need a hand and he writes back
he's like what and I'm like oh [__] oh I
told him that he was fine with it yeah
of all the comics probably the best one
to send it to an accident yeah
absolutely yeah of course because he's
the dirtiest guy ever yeah he was a bit
of a pig
but a nice guy and one of the most
famous
camera like you couldn't go anywhere him
sure and Sherman Hemsley whoa who I
remember me and Voss saw him do stand up
at Caroline's one time and it was kind
of sad it was like half full and he's
kind of coming on and off to The
Jeffersons but we went down to the
seller with him to have wings what and
homeless guys screaming at like
everybody knew that I sent him a dirty
text once did it really yeah no yeah
what that's hilarious you hung out with
him yeah I know I loved him you know who
had that was a deep cut you have to
Google this when kids at home Barry
Sobel I would walk around Midtown and
Barry Soul every black guy in New York
would come out of Windows Barry hey
buried I was like what the [__] he was
on Eddie Murphy's show or once said 227
once oh that was it
I thought as I hit that he's doing
stand-up where Barry Sobel used to do
like hip-hop like yeah he's like the
white rapper The Beastie Boy type guy
yes before anybody did that in comedy
really Barry Sobel started that that was
an epic Dangerfield lineup it was like
Barry Sobel Robert schimel Bill Hicks it
was like was that the dice one or no
dice was on it too wow yeah leafer uh
Dom Herrera wow I remember that one
because I watched that one like a ton
yeah Schimmel was so funny was amazing I
think uh that dice he said that one of
those other guys I was either Sobel or
might have been Robert Schimmel one of
them was gonna wear a leather jacket and
dice was the guy who wore it and then
they said no no dice wears the jacket
damn yeah I remember the first place I
was when I saw dice like you don't
usually remember that with Comics but I
was 18 and I was dating this girl and
she's like Jim come in here this guy's
so dirty and I sat down and we watched
this Dangerfield special and it's like
it I'd never seen anything like no
that's just that was insane it was so
Innovative and original yeah Tennyson
too I mean it's crazy how many amazing
Comics came from those Rodney specials I
remember seeing Nick Apollo too did
Seinfeld come yeah he was on that
Roseanne right yeah Roseanne I remember
Robert Townsend Bob Nelson yeah yeah
Robert Townsend did Bobby Austin die or
no was he said he made he was sick his
career did but I I think he's in Long
Island oh he I I don't know Bob I heard
he was sick and I was like he didn't die
did he no I don't think so he's got the
helmet on he's fine all right I feel bad
saying that you never want to wonder if
a comedian died it sounds disrespectful
but you know I'll cover that part all
right but wait you're gonna say
something Robert Townsend
um no maybe not no it was Robert there
was another name it was uh oh Nick de
Paulo first time I saw Nick I remember
it was on him and Janine and I forget
who else was I was an HBO young comedian
special I remember those specials were
[__] great too but I watched Nick
depaolo talking about if if uh testing
like monkeys can cure AIDS like because
people are complaining about primate
testing I was like this guy is [__]
mean yeah he's great his jokes were like
it was just like he's a machine so I
mean his first Letterman is Lights Out
it's so good it's clean and still great
yeah Nick is a very underrated comic
yeah he's a great guy some of the
classic jokes I always think about on
the road he's got so many good road
jokes I mean I think about the one about
uh checking of the hotel and seeing a
poop in your toilet and I called the
front desk I said you know most hotels
leave a mint on your pillow
yeah great joke and just the way he
would talk about is there anything we
could do to make yours your stay better
oh yeah how about you take the jet
engine out of the air conditioner which
is [__] just a shitty cranky Vibe
it's so funny man so funny he's got that
great joke about he gets hurt and he
goes to the uh emergency room and he
goes I don't want to say I waited a long
time but the guy before me at a musket
wound oh that's fine
is there a John Quincy Adams here
holy [__] yeah yeah he's a [__]
machine and what I like about Nick is
I've been in like writer situations with
him we did when tough crowd started it
was like it was Colin I think in Ken
Ober in one room Nick and Geraldo wrote
in the other room holy [__] like they
had different offices and you know
Sherrod Brian Tucker were out in this
main office and me and Keith
uh we're in one getting nothing dot like
Nick and Geraldo and Colin Keno but they
were writing sketches and me and Keith
did zero did absolutely nothing but Nick
is comfortable pitching jokes like he's
not ashamed to pitch jokes and fight
whether it works or not in a room and I
I always admire that because I'm so
afraid of doing that like I'm so ashamed
of course I don't collaborate well with
guys I like you write stuff whatever and
then I'll look at it and I'll write you
back it's right I don't collaborate well
in the moment well throwing it out there
it's so vulnerable and when it when it
bombs it [__] stings yeah yeah
because it's other guys who know what's
funny exactly I can't blame them for
being stupid yeah they get it
Comics you know I remember I remember
reading in your book you said it was
something about uh a tough crowd you
would do a joke where you would ask
people how they're doing and then just
slam them slam the door in their face
yeah and the only people you didn't do
it to were were Jon Stewart and Paul
Mooney oh I don't remember did I not do
it to those guys I think you said in the
book you were like I was too nervous to
do it to Paul move probably yeah I
wanted Mooney to like me because he uh
he wrote for prior and I love Richard
Pryor so much and Mooney was actually he
was a weird like I didn't know him well
but he was very nice to me I guess
because we had done that before and he'd
be on open Anthony and he was one of
those guys that would like test you a
little bit to see if you can handle B
and T's and he was always responsive if
you hit back like he was never he wasn't
a baby about it uh but I didn't know him
very well who got mad at me house Sparks
wow I think got mad because I got
everybody and it used to be I would
always be happy that Patrice or Nick
would like I would stand out and say so
you've been on the road I would just
kind of put my hand on the door and I
would see Patrice start to laugh because
he knew what was coming because no comic
doesn't want to talk about their Road
experience sure how's the road been well
I've been in that [__] door coming
close oh it was like beating cancer that
feeling but most people probably laughed
at that though all of them did pal I
think was I didn't know him well or at
all so I think he might have thought I
was a dick I think Colbert really
enjoyed like I got a few guys that you
wouldn't think yeah uh but he's like an
improv guy he probably was like you
probably I loved it he's like yeah this
guy's a douche and he got it he was he
was fine with it but I think that Hal is
the one and I didn't remember not doing
it to John or but you know John had the
daily shot is probably who the [__] am I
yeah you know true it's humiliating too
because he would like it I think he's a
fun guy yeah but I didn't have the faith
in I didn't like you know what I mean
like it was Jon Stewart so I probably
was trying to be respectful yeah but
you've met everybody I mean you got a uh
I've been to your apartment just the
people on your wall alone the photos you
have with people is insane yeah I have I
met every hero I've met I think wow I
think I've been lucky in that way I got
to meet Kennison briefly it was just
like a five minute he came out to the
open mic at Rascals and I didn't do
photos back then but he talked to some
of the young comics and I got him to
sign a napkin oh cool which I still have
um wow yeah I was like I was happy I got
to say hello to Amber Richard Pryor very
brief yeah I didn't get to talk to him
uh yeah I lit his cigarette I was with
Patrice actually at the comedy store in
dude
yeah because he had he was looking for
his lighter and I just lit his cigarette
yeah I it would have been hilarious if
the wind came through not again
but Patrice didn't walk up and talk to
him uh but I'm glad I did and I got him
to sign my business card which I still I
used to get autographs on the back of my
business card because it felt like it
was personal right so I got him to sign
that but I never got to talk to him it
was brief yeah I wish I had a photo wow
man remember business cards I used to
have 2 000 printed yeah from Vistaprint
for like eight bucks and I would pass
him out at open mics like a [__]
Chooch I had a little joke on it too it
would say Jim Norton build discreetly to
your Visa or Mastercard you know a
little phone sex you know folks for
those that like that
they would tell you all the comments
would be like you got to stand by the
door and hand out your business yeah
[__] well then I'm not gonna make it
do it I love the guy too it says like
director photographer comedian writer
actor and you're like all right what is
this Vaudeville yeah you can do
everything come on or are you getting
ahead and I had him it was humiliated
yeah when was your first headshots I I
was kind of talked into it an older
comic named Gemini uh John Lombardi's
you gotta get headshots like I just
weighted do you remember your first one
yeah Mindy Tucker we shot it on like the
sidewalk in Brooklyn and that was it it
was just a shitty yeah you know it was
bad I don't remember who it was but yeah
I remember getting them and I'm like
yeah I look [__] worse than I look
now yeah it's embarrassing right it's
embarrassing they're the worst I even
see him at the cellar and I'm like oh
these are all bad is that your favorite
part of it though like when you do like
the comedy Cabaret in Doylestown or even
like this or the old Atlanta punch line
I love looking at all those headshots on
the wall of people I don't know because
like when that guy you know what I mean
you know Mike steten you know yeah
Oklahoma right you see a guitar stem
right and you're like that guy had the
same dream I had yeah something new
Museum it's like it's you go to the
Royal Oak Comedy Castle it like wraps
around oh yeah like Gary shanling uh
Leno yes it's kind of you're like holy
[__] they played this room yeah right
then yeah you're right the ones you've
never heard of you're like what the [__]
is this what happened what is there like
kids death suicide what happened well I
remember one time it was like years ago
Joe Mackey and I were at the comic strip
and we were pointing we were like
there's some heavy guy with a mustache
and we were like laughing like who's
that guy and someone walked over they're
like he's not a comic he was the guy who
would do the delivery for the cash and
one night he got shot in the head oh wow
Jesus
tape a flower to his [__] picture all
right yeah we like you can't do that to
us yeah no but some of those uh some of
those headshots are like it's amazing
man amazing of the time you can tell the
time they were taken and I'm I would
never get bored of standing there
looking at people I don't know who they
are I could do that all day because I'm
just like what [__] happened to you I
know what mistakes did you make were you
not funny was this a part-time thing
were you a drunk yep I love those
stories too a lot of drugs in the 80s
I've been a lot of cokeheads oh yeah
don't you love those stories of guys who
like hey it's on The Tonight Show and
then he drank it like you learned from
those guys you're like I'm so glad I
didn't [__] if wherever I go I go but
I didn't wreck it by being
self-destructive were you when did you
become sober I was 18. I was like I get
up I was a young [__] Suburban uh uh
Problem Child but how did you know at 18
to go sober like I would go maybe I'll
drink less or I won't black out but to
go sober it's got to be tough my father
was sober in a program and I used to you
know I went to rehab for wrist slicing
and you know calling the FBI drunk I
used to call the clan members and tell
them how wrong they were I was an
[__] Suburban angst you know wow
you guys are doing great I remember that
dude I [__] I remember I read some
book on the clan and uh I was a little
sjw at 15 and I looked up his number on
information and he was a clan preacher
and I called him and I'm like it's wrong
that you're racist and he actually
talked to me on the phone he's like oh
well you know I don't do that anymore I
left and then we had like a chat he
talked to me on the phone this guy and
then I you know I don't remember what
happened after that but you joined sure
I was like well now that that [__] is
out there's an opening
that's amazing you called an ex-clan
yeah he's out 4-1-1 and you dial one
five five whatever the number was to
that local thing and the guy got him I
couldn't believe he got on the [__]
phone wow that's crazy I thought people
were accessible now with Twitter and
[__] you could just call it I still
don't like Jews
[Laughter]
yeah he admitted that he was wrong about
it I guess he was realized like
somebody's calling my the phone was
great back then because you didn't have
to worry like I remember calling and I
called in bomb threats to my high school
I actually cleared the high school I was
like we were all drunk uh me and my
friends I used to call this none thing
that they would like rescue problem kids
and I would always tell them I was being
molested and we would all giggle but I
cleared the school with a bomb threat I
get that I remember watching from my
friends like we were watching from his
patio whatever we could see people
walking into the parking lot wow because
I called in so it's like I get why I
would never have been a school shooter
but I get why people want that impact of
course why you want people to like
you've done something that moved the
need yes yes and when you do clubs on
the road I call in a bomb threat but
that would explain why the curtains
always pulled it's the worst one on
early show Saturday when they pulled the
curtain back I didn't know that was a
curve I thought I was just half
solder but uh I saw Tracy Morgan this is
years ago he was on Stern and he said he
would [__] he would go to the white
neighborhood to the community pool and
[__] in the pool and Howard Stern's like
why'd you do that he's like because
everyone had to go out of the pool it
was like a little power thing kind of
like the bomb threat wow I'm causing
these kids to get out this is on me I
did this yeah you have it in the poop in
the pool is a little more Hands-On yeah
yeah
yeah and then and then the downside is
you've had impact but you're not
standing with your own [__] with water I
mean they can kind of they can kind of
pick you out of a lineup at that point
yeah that's the guy fecal matter on his
elbows in a semi circle
that was a big move he said that's
hilarious the early school shooting was
[__] in the pool
nobody died yeah we might be drunk as
brought to you by Babble baby if you're
taking a summer trip abroad in 2023 you
might want to be able to walk but walk
and Tuck the tuck that's why you
shouldn't go anywhere without preparing
with Babel Babel is the language
learning app with addictively fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons so
there's still time to learn a new
language before you reach your
destination
I agree I travel a lot
I was just down in Mexico and it
embarrassed me embarrassing me that I
don't know Spanish I took it in high
school uh there's a Subway sorry
it's in real New York experience I'm
Underground
comedically and literally but uh yes get
on Babel learn a language expand your
mind queef it up
with lessons that take a little under 10
minutes a day you start having a
real-life conversation for almost three
weeks hey
choose from 14 different languages
including French Italian Portuguese and
more Babel 11 they're voiced by real
native speakers not computers and can
access podcast games video stories and
even live classes to help you on your
way plus comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee
pretty good
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
drunk that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com for up to 55 off your
subscription
language for life all right spring
cleaning is here boys time to clean out
those nasty holes oh yeah manscape
performance package 4.0 has it all the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer your
hair oof we got some old listeners you
need that tell me I'll look at it here
in the library
trim it feature proprietary Advanced uh
skin safe technology to protect your
delicate parts and holes yeah I trim
with this stuff and it's scary putting a
razor to your shaft but I'm not scared
when I'm using this [__] yeah right my
ball sack like hey we've all had that
fear you know you bleed out the little
fluid comes out of your ball sack not
with this stuff you got that right the
package also comes with their crop
preserver ball deodorant because he gets
smelly down there yep and crop reviver
ball toner smell as clean as a baby's
Bungholio always use the right tools for
the job head to their website and check
out all their tools to help you upgrade
your hygiene routine get 20 off and free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
drunk manscaped your balls will thank
you here here
hey folks drink zbiotics
you know it you love it you can't afford
to waste a day stuck on the couch
because of a few drinks the night before
zebiotics is the answer we've all been
looking for zebiotics pre-alcohol pro
probiotic is the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic uh it
was invented by PhD scientists to tackle
rough mornings after drinking here's how
it works when you drink alcohol oh when
you drink alcohol gets converted into a
toxic byproduct in the gut it's this
byproduct not dehydration that's to
blame for your rough day zebiotics
proves an enzyme to break this byproduct
down it's designed to work like your
liver but it's in your gut where you
need it most drink zebiotics before
drinking alcohol drink responsibly and
get a good night's sleep to feel your
best tomorrow
give zebiotics a try for yourself go to
zebiotics.com drunk to get 15 off your
first order when you use code drunk at
checkout thank you c-box is back with
100 money back guaranteed so if you're
unsatisfied for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember to head to ZBOX drunk and use
code drunk at checkout for 50 off thank
you zebiotics for sponsoring this
episode
that's like I mean that other kid do you
see the they had the article about this
kid by the way his last name sturgeon
which like uh you know they're like hoop
star popular kid shoots up a school I
guess he shot like four people in the
bank yesterday oh the Kentucky yeah
I think oh wow it was a bank bank guy he
had gotten fired and he um but there's a
weird I wonder if he had CTE because he
had like this like I think OJ had CTE
I'm guessing they'll figure out when
he's dead oh yeah but they said you got
so many concussions he had to wear a
helmet when he played basketball I
thought it was a typo in the article I
thought he was like it was like well you
know he's baseball and he wore like a
helmet in the field or something yeah
I've never seen a dude play basketball
in a [__] helmet yeah it looked
insane yeah he looked like an ass yeah
and you know so I think that's probably
why you know maybe and he was dunking in
the picture I'm like maybe don't show a
picture the school Shooter's slowing
down yeah exactly exactly so I'm going
like this
you can't show him taking a shot
sorry very good marker
I should get a helmet
but yeah I'll be right back well I think
there's a Colorado guy they stopped him
he was going to shoot up a school and
they stopped him
um I kind of vaguely remember that it
was like a week ago was it like from
[__] he had written uh yeah I think so
and I think they caught him on the way
in with the gun and they just grabbed
him I was thinking today I was talking
to my trainer at the gym they should
have something on guns where like all
apps can detect when there's a gun
nearby so like if a gun gave up like
like we had that fine mile when you lose
your keys yes some kind of an app that
can tell you and like everything but
with police or something right so you
don't know when they're coming to bust
you you get the [__] alert that's a
great idea yeah I mean gun owners would
never go for having a little thing put
on their weapon but still I guess but he
can make it a law and and some guys just
have them right here anyway so they're
already visible
yeah but uh that's a great call I know
but nobody will go nobody will go for it
well do you guys stay on while he's
pissing you're good right yeah we're
okay good I never piss I've wet the BET
as a kid so I've built my bladders this
big I did two and I I wet the bed as an
adult I pissed the bed multiple times as
an adult even with my girlfriend in bed
I'm like yeah I pissed a little bit I've
done that too yeah it's embarrassing
well I only do it when I black out
drinking but you do it I'm sober totally
sober wow yeah one too many coffees
after 3 P.M and I pissed the bed yeah
this is what's bedtime for you because
you got the morning show I get I go to
bed by 12 and I get up at like 6 45 but
I usually don't fall asleep to like 12
45 1 o'clock I'm a bad sleeper same and
I get up at like uh like I envy your
life though like when you look at you
and Sam you guys who are doing like that
nightlife I love that life of going
going around one o'clock in the morning
I got a spot or you can go to like the
party at the cellar tomorrow night I uh
I gotta be home like by 9 30 10 o'clock
like a [__] old lady it sucks but do
you kind of like the structure like all
right I know where my money's coming in
I know where my my job is is there
anything to that or do you like or do
you hate the structure no I like the
fact that it makes me go to the I'm able
to go to the bank and do normal person
things oh yeah because when I have all
night to myself I'm just basically I'm
online all night I'm jerking off I'm
watching it's just dysfunctional I do my
spots I go to bed at 7 A.M yeah like
when I was doing tough crowd I would go
to bed at like uh seven o'clock eight
o'clock in the morning wow wake up
sometimes if I had a no episode that day
I would sleep until 4 30. oh
um or if I had an episode I would go to
bed at like five and get up at one like
it was just totally upside down and then
nothing gets done nothing gets done and
you become depressed because you're like
oh now I'm up and the sun's down and
then now I'm up or down and the sun's up
it's it's [__] with your cerebellum I
don't know serotonin whatever whatever
it is yeah we're talking about going to
just being upside down like I envy your
schedules that you guys are just out
like living Road comic lives like I love
that schedule oh really yeah being up
all night oh yeah yeah and you just
can't do it because of the radio you
mean yeah it sucks like it's like having
a it lets you have like a real life
where you can okay I can do these things
I would never I wouldn't have a mortgage
if I was up on like so I just wouldn't
have would have went to the bank but now
I'm like yeah I kind of feel like a
regular person and you still get a set
in I do two a night yeah yeah that's
great yeah I usually do Monday through
Monday through Saturday uh two at night
I was only doing one before the pandemic
but when if the pandemic I was like I
wanted to just kind of get my [__] back
and I just love doing to a night now to
a night's huge how much does the radio
burn you out riding it helps because you
start thinking of in directions you
wouldn't think of like you're reading
news stories every day and you're like
oh yeah is there an angle on that is
there not a funny angle on that and
normally the answer of course no but I
mean you try and it gets your mind
working that's smart you guys use I mean
you do so much I mean that helps you do
so much topical stuff I guess sometimes
you do podcasts you're just like I just
feel like it it hurts my writing because
I'm just like I only have so much
creativity in my head per day and I'm
just burnt the [__] out but I guess if
you have
news stories you're like this is like a
goal that is that day it's it's not it's
a lot it's live like people are
listening now so I know that it's like
whatever we're doing we're gonna burn
um so get it out of the way and then
tomorrow it's got to be something new so
it kind of feels like you have to Rifle
through news stories real quick and see
what's if there's anything a lot of
times we don't get to them but I read
them anyway yeah I think that's healthy
and then that's a good exercise just
going all right I need a Dylan Mulvaney
joke yeah you know it gets the brain
going well I write on stage I'm really
Colin is so good like you'll see him
with like a chicken scratch papers and I
don't not do it out of artistic anything
I'm just not good at that
um I'm much better at writing on stage
and part of it is probably laziness like
I just sure I get an idea like you know
how it is you just talk it through and
see what's there but writing it down is
probably so much better I think so
because I always say I'm gonna write it
on stage and then I get up there and
that wave of like oh this isn't going
that well and I get frazzled and then I
can't think of anything yeah I've gotten
used to that over the decades I think oh
did I [__] eat [__] last night oh not
not even aggressive but I was bombing
and they didn't hate me they were just
like no we're not enjoying what you're
doing yeah and I don't know if it was a
bunch of trans stuff after Judy Gold had
gone on so maybe we hit the same topic
you know what I mean we might have hit
it in a similar way I haven't seen Judy
set in years so yeah it could have been
that with like yeah we just kind of
heard something along this shirt highway
I don't know yeah and Judy Rants and
Raves so she can cover everything yeah
she's funny too hilarious yeah do you
ever do you ever um feel like following
people with the seller with
the amount of new stuff you do I mean I
I feel this sometimes you're following
some new guy at the cellar and they just
are murderers and they're doing their
greatest hits yeah the a game and then
you go on you're like this happened the
news today and the crowd just like what
yeah if you're not as Zippy as they are
they kind of like oh is this guy bombing
because some of the new Comics there are
[__] Killers they're killing yeah and
they're and they're not doing new [__]
because they they're at the the seller
and they don't want SDC I don't like SD
seeing me Bob I mean this is 1995 and
she walks out
[__] but John Bobbitt just [__] I
I fall apart so no I don't really I
don't care who I'm following there uh
because there so many of them kill
um and on the road you got to follow
guys that are [__] murdering and yeah
over the years at the seller you know
you got to follow Chappelle like I
remember one weekend I was every he was
working at a Showtime special so he was
doing longer sets and I was on after
remember you know you just you get used
to like not giving a [__] yeah but uh
the top the only thing I care about is
like I'll ask somebody hey did you do
anything on the Dalai Lama like if rogel
comes off for anybody because you don't
want to do the exact same subject but
um but then you have guys like David
tell who are so good that he goes on
last and everyone's done the Dalai Lama
but his is still the best one because it
never you never see it it's so infuriate
you never see it coming I know he's that
good he like yeah you never see his joke
like he throws a curveball even though
we know how jokes are structured and
[__] Dave every [__] time I know I
I was out of left field I wonder if he's
in his apartment going no no is he is he
punching himself in the face is he
pacing like how does he come up with it
I don't know probably he's probably some
weird process yeah he probably just sits
on the toilet and flip-flops smoking
it's probably something that you
wouldn't think of yeah Anthony jeselnick
will do the same [__] too like I don't
yes I never guessed the punchline and
you're trying the whole time okay I got
it yeah but I never guess it no same and
with him it's it's it is fresh because
jessalink is so good he's very much he
has a certain Pace to his jokes and a
certain where walking here we're walking
here and I'm gonna hit you and the punch
line is still coming from where you
don't see it coming from he's great yeah
he's really really good who's not a good
writer I just saw
um I was like [__] the Ricky Velez I
watched Ricky Velez at the Patrice
benefit oh yeah and he was talking and
he followed dice who [__] killed um
wow and then Ricky goes on and he's
talking about a soup kitchen and
depression and all this real [__] yeah
but it was so funny I'm like this guy is
really good because the writing is so
good and they be killed he followed him
with really personal stuff yeah he
didn't [__] Panic uh it was good to
watch a guy like that he's not even a
young comic anymore he's been around but
I've known it was probably 18 or 19.
yeah I remember he was just this kid
like sprawled out in the [__] yeah
room at the Broadway comedy club right
right but uh yeah no it's awesome it's
awesome to see like people just you know
become who they are to watch them not
panic like to watch a guy in front of
2500 people following a guy who is a
legend and who is really funny still
funny guys still funny yeah and to watch
this guy just walk up and do his own
[__] thing and he's a bronx yeah like
I don't care how long someone's in the
game like you watch a guy like that and
you're inspired by it you're like yeah
man you just do what you do don't ever
worry about with the guy in front of you
totally totally yeah that Patrice
benefit is so [__] fun because we all
do all these little sets all over the
city and then you get to do this theater
in the middle of Manhattan with these
it's like Bill Burr Jon Stewart was on
that one right yeah yeah so John yeah
insane did you close the door in his
face I no I didn't I forgot that I had
done that but I'm probably even after
all this time still too much of a coward
to do it to him because it's like hey
he's gonna get something soon
maybe he'll have me on
um sorry oh no I heard he threw out a
couple of R's and F's out there he did
yes yes I love it all right it's Stuart
what about uh Stuart how well did he
know patrice's comedy because I remember
when Geraldo passed away he did a really
nice piece on Geraldo but I I didn't
know like how familiar John is with the
truth oh no man I'm sure that by this
point like you know Ricky Gervais loves
Patrice like he says his favorite
comedian so because of everything in the
special and all this material he might
have Reef like you a lot of guys just go
back and watch stuff so I don't know how
familiar but I'm sure he knew his stuff
because we were doing tough crowd while
he was doing The Daily Show so you
couldn't not know Patrice he's on so
often
um an elephant in the room kills uh I've
never seen the whole thing no I was
there when he shot some of it I think I
went in between shows to see him but
um or I came in because we had the same
manager Jonathan so I might have stopped
it I think he might have been on stage I
don't remember but it's hard to I can't
really watch his [__] it's too it's too
difficult but occasionally so close yeah
it makes me sad but I'll watch like an
occasional on a bit or something I'll
listen to him like it always makes me
laugh yeah yeah he was so good off the
cuff and his dinner was great Courtney
Wilson Vince he did two hours that night
oh yeah yeah yeah elephant in the room
there's so much there's so much
unreleased stuff too that like would he
want that would he not want that
dollars but that's tough I know right
but hey if I die and it can make people
money in my family just release it yeah
I don't care I don't think this race
would give a [__] are you gonna cancel
me yeah that's not the Mr P album which
yeah which is right did that have his
Blessing or I don't know
um I don't know I know Jonathan who's
against still my manager
um I I know that he's careful about that
stuff and he's very protective and he
was really good with getting like all
these royalties and kind of because
Patrice was not the most [__]
organized uh guy with his finances so
Jonathan was good at helping get
everything or in order and get to his
family you know yeah yeah yeah wow yeah
his his Ona stuff I still go back and
listen to it it's great because that's
one thing not to blow you but you guys
added a a buddy element to comedy comedy
was it always had Edge you had your
kinesins your dice your Eddie Murphy but
you guys had that tough crowd group and
I think people love a group you know
people like it these are the Rogan Guys
these these are the LA guys this is the
This Crew over here you guys started the
crew thing I think well it was also as
the internet was getting like all these
things kind of got passed around in a
different way too so like this just
[__] on each other and then Colin
managed to turn it into a TV show right
um and we would do it all the time and
then just coming on Opie and Anthony
even the first version of that which was
on any W in the afternoon playing each
other's old tapes
um and they crucified me I'll stand up
from 93 was so bad it was who was in the
room it was Colin it was boss Patrice
might have been there and Paul Mercurio
I think I don't remember who was there I
want to say it was Colin Patrice and
Voss
um and then just having yourself
crucified like that on the radio it was
humiliating I can't imagine Colin's like
I can't even look at him but if this
make you Fearless at a certain point
because you're like what else can they
[__] yeah it's almost like eight mile
when he just arrest himself right what
else when you get used to the one
advantage to that like we were just
friends [__] on each that's all it
was yeah but when you are used to being
called out on everything by guys who are
legitimately funny you know Bill Burr
and and [__] and Colin and these guys
are ruthless when they call you out
Bobby Bobby's a mean [__] oh yeah Bobby
Kelly is a [__] you know what and he
catches himself but these guys calling
you out on stuff you knew they were
right like you know what I mean like
we're taking each other to hack Court
which was always so hardcore from what
I've heard it's you take someone's bit
and you base you break down whether or
not attacking whether or not you're a
hack and it was always Keith and Patrice
and Kevin and it was like nobody was
rooting for the other guy like
believe you did not have a lot of
Defenders it was all like we want to
call you a hack yeah
um but it did make you more aware of
like I have to write good stuff because
again you see guys like Colin going on
well when Patrice aguan he was just such
a naturally funny person right you feel
guilty and like I'm gonna get [__] on
coming with the same thing every night I
remember being on one night and just
doing some weak joke and Colin walking
through the room and he just went nice
writing lazy and he walked out and it
made me laugh I wasn't mad at him and
the crowd didn't understand but I knew
he was right it was a [__] [__] like
you know what I mean L.A you know New
York people are different type of
[__] level of [__] sure and when you
have guys that are going to make fun of
you you you kind of I mean if a comic
did that now it'd be like front page
comedy talk yeah that'd be like look at
this dick going through talking to him I
said heckling me what a piece of [__]
also do you think Comics would ever do
it to your [__] face I feel like now
it's all in Social that's true and now
it's like to get engagement right this
person saw bucks and it's like to get
retweets and you hate it oh yeah it's
it's there's no kindness behind it like
what Collins doing is actually warm oh
yeah and he knew I could take it and he
knew I would gladly yell at him like it
was a friend it was never right there
wasn't an ounce of anything shitty he
knew it would make me laugh uh yeah but
if it was a different thing he would
have you know started a new Twitter
handle anonymously I would know who it
was though yeah hey mumbling old idiot
insulted me oh I see Mark or Joe in the
doorway doing this doing my set I
[__] laugh every time we dude he's
making the [__] stink face at Keith
Robinson I got yelled at for that there
was a comic and uh we would do it to
each other all the time you [__] suck
like just to try to distract each other
yeah so I was doing it to a comic I knew
on stage at the cellar and um like
[__] yeah and then he saw me at the
cell later that night and he goes what
the [__] was that oh yeah he exploded on
me like I was like he was a bigger guy I
was like what the [__] and he goes you
[__] [__] above about like really
[__] vicious whoa I was like I'm
sorry man like I was just having fun
with you like I was really I didn't know
what to do because I was there was no
ill intent yeah it turned out he hey we
didn't know each other that well I guess
but he had just quit smoking and when
you quit smoking I remember I had a big
fight with Colin when I quit smoking I
was crying like I was I was your
emotions are [__] crazy sure the male
version of being pregnant yes it really
is uh and I was we I was so upset and
it's like when you quit smoking you're a
[__] maniac and he did apologize for
that he's like I'm sorry man I just but
uh yeah some guys didn't take as well
there's always something behind it it's
usually not about this thing it's always
something internal thing going on yeah
because I didn't mean it I was just
having fun it was fun telling someone
they I love looking at Marina on stage
yeah and knowing they catch your eyes
wow that's the last time I [__] with
Ben Bailey
geez no it wasn't bad I think Ben we all
know is crazy enough to [__] throw
you through a window oh yeah oh yeah
I've heard stories yeah everybody knows
Ben has a [__] you know Ben's a great
guy but you know yes it is funny when
people try to [__] with your setup I was
definitely drunk on stage the other
night and uh Rachel Feinstein and Liz
are in the doorway just doing this my
entire set
that's like such a great it's fourth
grade so you're like all right that's
great we used to I remember when Voss
was on stage at Caroline's one time and
you know the curtain was uh pulled to
the shock of no one and uh me and
Florentine were on different sides of
the room and like Florentine used to
love to start groans
so like vloss is on and and and I'm on
one side and Jim is on the other but it
was Jim's thing and he would go like oh
I bet you hear people groaning and it
was so we ruined his whole set of 40
minutes of it and while she's going what
the [__] and he's snapping at the
audience and it really wrecked his set
and he had no idea that it was coming
from us uh that was satisfying that's
great yeah and he's an easy guy to grown
at yeah oh he is yeah is he offensive is
it awful who knows right either both I'm
just going to get the Fedora when I was
a young comic I did a bringer show at
Caroline's and my mom came and I [__]
sucked but my Mom saw Rich Voss and he
said to a woman later you're a two on a
Tuesday and my mom told me she goes he's
repulsive
here's why he's repulsive because he
used the syllable two on a Tuesday
that's why he's repulsive yes lady
you're a three on a Tuesday is funnier
two on a Tuesday sounds like he got
caught up in your word right right too
yeah it's all right no is this an insane
thing that you go to a comedy club you
get done up and Rich Vos goes you're a
two one yeah
well had the woman heckled him or
something she probably said something he
didn't like probably but it I mean I was
laughing but yeah it's
I did a country club gig at like a rich
hoity-toity Long Island Country Club and
it was me Vos Jessica Kirsten and
somebody else and everybody I had to go
first I ate [__] I died these people
weren't having it Kirsten goes up
murders and then Voss was last and I was
like how's he gonna do this he annihil
it he trashed everybody in the room and
they loved it he did it sitting on a
stool
he has a crazy Chris Voss is so fat his
thinking is so fast yeah he's he's will
butcher a word he'll say the dumbest
[__] uh but like he's like great minds
think a lot there's no iron
but his mind there's such a genius to
the way his mind works and he'll just
sit there and it's so confident he
[__] murders that well you think he
can't follow people or whatever he slows
them Todd Barry I admire too because
Todd will always talk at his own pace
yes never change and he brings people in
and that's what Voss does he has the
ability to do that I I panic well it
couldn't be more different but yeah
you're totally right I mean and Voss the
quickness I remember at the roast Colin
called him the master of the counter
punch yes holy [__] so true that is Voss
yeah he is he's uh and he can get beat
up for a lot it's fun by the way when
guys like that are murdering you like
when you walk in like the worst would be
when you would walk in and you'd hear
like and like Keith was already laughing
before you got in and you're like I know
I'm gonna get attacked yeah but having
funny people just attack You Is Fun like
it would make me laugh that these guys
who are so good at being mean yes are
[__] on me you cannot enjoy that I
was walking around the corner last night
from the McDougall room to the village
underground room on my phone sending an
email and I just hear Look up stupid and
it's Keith on a cane walking by me I'm
like he just he'll never say it's
amazing he'll never stop I love it he
also never complains too Keith is Keith
I've never met a person who complained
more when they were healthy and less
when they weren't he is [__] amazing
Keith never feels sorry for himself
never complains he does his material
he's like I'm an [__] I deserve it
like Keith is a really interesting guy
the fact that he his material is so
[__] funny yes new [__] is insane
it's crazy yeah it's so fun and he's on
he's on like with you being teased and
made fun of you say anything to him he
doesn't care yeah he'll laugh and you
call him the n-word he would just laugh
try it
[Laughter]
and I was sitting down at the table with
Keith and I was like oh it was excellent
he goes shut the [__] up
describe that movie as excellent to a
black man
it was a good movie
but I still shouldn't have said it that
way yeah yeah yeah he'll uh Keith will
call you out on it but the guy we would
always talk about Ray those guys were
never sensitive to him no no they knew
where it was coming from he was just
having a conversation about what gets
people in trouble and there was never
any like hey watch what you're saying
yeah to Keith or Patrice or Kevin those
guys didn't know we were at the seller
one time and it was like a headline news
this black guy was shot in Philly and we
were all like talking about it kind of
tiptoeing and people is what'd he do and
so I said the story and he's like he
deserved it you're like okay there you
go Kate the proves but everyone else is
like no he's the victim whatever but he
was just like man I [__] that guy yeah
I've been with Keith from the police
bothered us I dropped him and Patrice
might have been him Patrice and Kevin
they lived in Woodbridge together at the
time I think so I drove them and it was
just me and those three in a parking lot
we're just talking and a cop pulled up
and wanted what are you guys doing here
so I'm being and Keith wow we're just
pocket and I'm like dude we [__] shut
up yeah right immediately
confrontational immediately wow yeah I
mean Keith was uh he's raised in a very
tough Philly area sure so he did not get
along with the police but I've seen it
firsthand how fast he went from zero
like funny Keith was out the window and
it was what the [__] do you guys want
interesting yeah which uh you know I
groveled and talked my way out of a
problem but yeah I was like [__] come
on man what are you doing so I don't
know if you know this but I had for my
audition of the seller I had to follow
you did you yeah it was 2013 it was the
height of like the radio show yeah so
you got a huge pop and people are
yelling stuff at you like inside jokes
and all that I was [__] trembling on
the side of the stage and then a girl
walked by and she was super hot and she
had huge boobs and you were in the
middle of a bit and you're like whoa
what's your name sister and she's like
I'm Sheila and you're like I'm gonna
[__] Sheila in the bathroom and you're
killing with all this [__] and I was
just going up there with my dumb jokes I
was terrified well obviously you killed
look at you now I mean you [__] got
into the cellar and you're selling out
of theaters well
what is he calling about and then uh I
remember I was like playing a [__]
in Somerville South Carolina I remember
that week oh I never even heard of that
town yeah it ain't good damn but yeah I
remember uh yeah I remember that night
yeah and I only the only reason I got
over on the audience because they were
still buzzing from your Set uh I just
said well I was dating Sheila until a
minute ago
saved me if I didn't have that riff I
wouldn't have gotten in that's hilarious
it's funny but it was a risk it was a
risk she used to audition people I think
when I auditioned there it was on a I
got into selling dangerfields in the
same day Rick Dorfman was my manager at
the time when he worked for Caroline's
and I this is like before he went out on
his own and I think I don't know who you
have to follow but she would put you on
like after Angel Salazar and he would
[__] annihilate on a late show Friday
like it wasn't a lot of times I think
now it's earlier but back then there was
only a couple of shows so you would go
on a lot of times on The Late Show
Friday Friday yeah and it was it was
rough but uh I obviously and that's the
the worst show yeah always oh yeah yeah
they're drunker they're tired but you
had to do well to good but there were
less spots there anyway you know I mean
there was there was x amount of spots
and then food spots right
um which you know I did for years you
just got paid in a meal was the seller
the seller then or was it just a club no
it's a club I mean it was the seller but
it was half sold on a Monday it would be
one long show started at like 9 p.m and
I did food spots for years and gnome saw
me once because he should be on regular
page bots so they gave me a paid spot
but I bombed uh right back to food spots
for a while what does that mean you get
a free meal and not a paycheck you get
10 yeah it would happen like 11 or 12 it
would switch to 20 minute paid spots to
10 minute food spots and everybody like
you know myself Russ benev Judah all
those guys would just do 10 minutes and
you get paid in a full meal damn because
that's when you want to eat midnight
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or you go in
earlier Russ Ben Eve would always eat
for six people he was amazing watching
that impulsive idiot [__] Shuffle it
is inspirational like Russ is getting
his [__] money's worth but it made
you better yeah you had to be funny or
you wouldn't get spots anymore CBS but
we got free meals oh man that was good
food that was great food I remember oh
the Wayne Rader yes yes
pocketing a lot of that money oh yeah oh
yes that was interesting now what do you
think about this and feel free to kick
me in the balls here you get a free meal
every show and the food was incredible
it's like chicken marsala was like
high-end [__] you're all poor so this
was like a big deal yes so I had just
eaten and I got the free meal ticket or
whatever and I said I'm gonna come back
tomorrow and cash this in so I came back
tomorrow and they're like you don't get
a free meal the day's over I'm like but
I did the set
so where where what do you think here I
think that um you're broke at that time
I think they should have uh given you
the free mail but but but never allowed
you to come back in again
I think they should have given you a
meal and said take it to go yeah I mean
a female for a guy you never forget the
places that [__] you like that that
won't feed you I know it was a fight I
brought a date there on New Year
where was that it was on the corner of
uh McDougall and Bleaker yeah and I
bombed in front of her but then we ate
we ate a good meal oh there you go did
you [__] your date yeah we were dating
it oh it wasn't just the first is there
anything worse when you bring a girl to
a [__] show then you go up there and
you [__] oh you [__] the bed I
brought a girl I was currently [__]
she was a cute blonde and she loved the
fact I was a stand-up but turned her on
and I brought her a show and I ate [__]
and she never [__] me again oh wow
yeah did she say anything about it she
was like well you gotta get out of here
you know and I was like well the crowd
was tough I tried some new stuff she was
like all right she was already in a cab
yeah that's the worst because that like
a lot of times any girl that's ever
[__] me it's never a [__] physical
it's always like a personality thing or
the thing about being a stand-up right
when they see you bomb it's like the
little bit of emoji you had is gone
exactly for what you are yeah man we get
[__] for being like oh she's too heavy
or whatever but if they see me bomb it's
over yes fat chick the worst I'm doing
the more my side fat and tits are
visible
[Laughter]
Fitzsimmons has that great thing where
he's like after a good set you're a
superhero for three hours but once that
three hours goes away you start if you
don't hook up with a girl within that
time or get back to her place or
whatever it is it starts fizzling you're
a superhero at that location yes yes you
take him to another location those
Powers don't work you're Clark Kent yeah
yeah you got you gotta you gotta rope
her into your thing like she has to Like
You by the time that time is up right
then when you go out then she's like oh
okay I already like this guy and you
know the first impression was a a good
first impression yeah well what are you
68 54 54. I will be 68 hopefully
keep taking that prep but he by the way
by the way the fact that I gave you a
lit this is why I should be drummed out
of Show Business the fact that you're
riffing and I go no I'm 54.
[__] weak chin idiots
but do you are you getting the ladies
like oh I like older men this is hot
because yes my age group is a no-go no I
think there's a lot of ladies who are
into the uh from my end it's a no-go
not that I'm gonna [__] anyone who can
get pregnant anyway at this point in my
life
um no yeah I they tend to date uh young
I have a girlfriend I've had her for a
girlfriend for a while it's like it's
weird not and you're living together
yeah yeah whoa that's a big step it is
yeah and I like it I mean uh it's like
the other [__] even when I'm single if
I'm not [__] a lot of girls you jerk
you off you're watching porn it's
endless it's an endless cycle of
dopamine that makes you feel bad when
you're done so I actually like it well
it's good to come and not be sad well I
didn't say that
I didn't say that
I mean I come and then all of a sudden
she'll take the Rope off her neck and
get down from the stool
put it on your neck yeah thanks for the
visual then you come yeah no I uh the
sex is but it becomes I like being a
little domestic because for I would
never have been it's the first time I've
ever lived with anybody it's the first
time I've ever done this stuff and like
when I was 53 it started so I was like
yeah I like it I like I've done every
other angle and uh being the first time
you've lived with someone never did it
before wow never that's impressive you
made it that long I know but it's like
now I'm all these things I'm like my
life is a hack 80s set like you know
what I mean you hold the purse on the
wall like all the stuff I never did I'm
doing now so I like it though it makes
me feel human yeah I cook together all
that stuff yeah yeah you should cook
like fresh fish and stuff and I just
think I'm so happy she's there yeah I'm
like I really love her and I'm like I'm
happy she's at my place like this once
in a while you're like [__] I would love
to but then like ah that stuff always
made me feel bad yeah exactly and the
head games of like she didn't respond or
maybe I'm being too annoying or whatever
and just worrying about what she's
thinking and if she likes yeah all that
[__] it's an addiction the dating stuff
oh yeah there's apps and stuff you're
just like this is a [__] it and then
you you're not satisfied you want to
like meet someone else it it's oh it
it's never ending completely it's not
Carlin had a thing he talked about like
with people taking different like you
know vehicles on trips but he was he
said too many choices in America it's
not healthy yeah and he was so right
like it's not healthy for me when I can
just swipe or look online it's like
there's no there's nothing invested in
any of these it's just a moment a moment
a moment and then you're just alone I
mean how many times you sift through
Netflix for like two hours you never
even picked anything you just kept
sifting and then you're done you're like
I gotta go to bed that's a great Point
TV you had cable and you were like this
is
casinos on I'm watching it we're
watching something recently where the
God it was some it was I was watching
this movie really good movie by the way
good wreck if you haven't seen it blow
out the De Palma movie is that without
John Travolta Nancy Allen yeah a really
good movie I'd never seen it but uh
anyway there's a local newscaster and
he's like my show gets 8 million viewers
and you're like a local news show that
like people didn't have options and
that's kind of good it was better
because you know what when it's [__] on
TV you watch less TV that's right and
now when you can do anything like Tick
Tock Mark and I were talking about this
when we were walking over here we were
just like holy [__] the amount of [__]
on Tick Tock right now the amount of
options the fact that it knows you you
just it's it is crack yeah it is so hard
it's hard for us adults to get off it
like I can't imagine what it's like for
kids oh my God I know my lady is younger
than me and I'll go to the bathroom and
I can tell she's like oh I can look at
Tick Tock for three minutes or whatever
two minutes and I'm like geez that's an
addiction it's hard not to because
there's really interesting stuff too
it's like a lot of it is [__] but a lot
of it is like I'm watching pilots in
turbulence and I'm like I've never been
able to see that I want to see what it
looks like
I want to watch a guy climbing a
building with no harness yeah they have
all those like Urban climbers like
there's a lot of [__] that's interesting
to watch well you're going wholesome I
thought your Tick Tock would be a lot
crazy I don't have Tick Tock I took it
off the phone though I mean I got a 13
year old camel toe twerking really in
yoga pants look at different Algos
you know I just didn't like Tick Tock
they said that like it spot it got too
much of your information I'm just like
yeah it's not my thing anyway I don't do
great on so Democrats and Republicans
are like there's like the one issue
they're coming in that's true to destroy
Tick Tock that's true only because it's
Chinese and they think that the Chinese
government is using it here's what
happened with Tick Tock it'd be dumb if
they were using it they of course they
would right the American the Chinese
Chinese government will like remove its
interest or ability to check it and then
it will stay they're not going to take
it off the app so I don't think so
really I don't care if they do it on it
so I don't care well it's funny because
they're acting like Facebook and all
this [__] isn't doing the same thing
they're all taking the data I know but
it's our country taking the day it's
American and they probably can monitor
it easier they can the regulations for
American companies are probably
different than in communist China it's
probably harder to get information and
then the irony is China only allows you
to use tick tock for like two hours a
day so does it really yeah they have a
governor on it and we don't
and it's their app and they're probably
like if you if they wanted to you could
you know make us look at anti-American
[__] probably yeah yeah anything else
true and it's young people on there true
they probably have more algorithm
control oh for sure yeah I just can't do
it I'll look at that once in a while on
Instagram but I'm like yeah I like the
camel toe stuff too or I'll see like
workout video but I'm like this is just
awful on the road it's bad though the
last time I'm trying not to jerk off and
the last time I was on the road in doubt
I was a [__] it was just like
literally all three days yeah hours of
Journey doesn't that suck when you're
like all right and then you're just like
nah I'm just gonna jerk off yeah I don't
write I type with my left hand
there's a difference
um because my girlfriend wasn't with me
yeah but I got to a point recently where
I'd wait for her to fall asleep and just
sit in the other room and [__] uh
yeah I do that too it's like when a
married guy does like you know what I
mean like ah yeah this is what my life
is I know it's like your mom again you
know you're like oh I can't let her find
out you're hiding socks Oh I thought
you're gonna say I have to hope she
walks in
yeah I gotta ask you about uh one of
your specials where you have DeNiro
oh yeah that's insane you had [__]
Robert De Niro in the intro of it was
one of your Netflix yeah it was it was
the one Netflix yeah I did the other
ones I did for epics and HBO but yeah I
got into this thing where I would get
people I love to intro me I had Aussie
do it one year wow Michael K Williams
from The Wire Michael K Williams yeah
with that that got one of the biggest
pops ever because my face uh everybody
knew I was obsessed with Omar from The
Wire and we finally interviewed him and
uh it started with my face and tape on
my mouth and then people saw him lean in
and then he he uh said something he just
licked my head in the place went [__]
wow that was a highlight but but DeNiro
how do you how did you approach him for
that I texted him I asked him I I asked
him I asked Michael I knew him so I uh
we had he we interviewed him finally in
Opie and Anthony and he recognized me
from Lucky Louie oh wow and then I would
see him occasionally after that and we
traded numbers and I just texted him
said we do it he goes yeah I would and
he didn't ask for the script I also with
De Niro I didn't show him the full
script either I had written to his
people years before that because I
wanted dinero to introduce me and I
never heard back but then we I worked on
that movie the comedian with him and uh
Taylor hackford who was the director
because I didn't ask for any extra money
when I helped with certain jokes I was
fine with it and he goes well Bob really
likes you you could just ask him wow um
because I've had meetings with Taylor
and De Niro just talking about stand up
or whatever it was so bizarre yeah I was
so scared that I wasn't scared it was
like I'm just sitting it was just me De
Niro and [__] Taylor hackford sitting
having coffee talking I heard they're
both awesome I heard yeah I mean Taylor
was was great to me he can be very tough
um but he loved me because I was just
throw out joke ideas and we just clicked
for some reason so I think he helped
pave the way with that and I asked um I
sent a message to De Niro through his
paper and they wrote back Bob would love
to do this wow I couldn't [__]
believe of it but the PO I wanted De
Niro to spank me uh but I kept that out
uh of the thing and I think that uh I I
when I sat down with him in his office
uh because his assistant said hey why
don't we get everybody out and just let
Jim and Bob talk about what this is
going to be and he's amazing because
he's like what do you want me to do like
you're directing him you're you're
telling him what you want
um and I told him and I got this gonna
be a thing right well you spank me I go
but I brought like uh I brought like a
brush for you uh because I don't care
I'm like good remember you said that
because I'm like I'm gonna drop my
[__] pants yeah get over your lap so
we're doing the scene and he's slapping
me
um and he trade goes you want me to miss
you and I'm like no hit me and so he hit
me lightly and I'm like I'm like no you
should really you're like Dunaway in
Chinatown I'm like well like him in
[__] Raging Bull come on Hit Me
Harder right but I'm told them to really
hit me and he did he slapped the [__]
out of me and it hurt and then when he
spanked me I pulled my pants down got
over his lap and he spanked me but then
I he goes let's do one where we're
standing gee and that was the one we
wound up using he was right he just knew
how that would play on camera and he
[__] he was he was so it murdered on
the special wow but that was uh yeah I
was very lucky I also Gervais and Louis
were in that opening too Louis was the
hardest one to get Louis was the busiest
and uh he was the last one I finally
shot wow but um yeah Ricky uh Ricky did
it and then Louie and then DeNiro was
like at the end but yeah that's I'll
never top that yeah it's gonna be hard
to do a special after that because that
that's so big it's hard to follow it
yeah I'll probably I I mean I'm ready to
shoot something now I'll probably just
YouTube it and and do very poorly and
have to have everybody see how poorly
the numbers are going uh well I'll push
the hell out of it but I want but I'll
never top that I'll never again no
that's insane and that was was that the
one Netflix one where you did it you did
like that one crowd work moment in there
I think so oh yeah somebody said
something and I just kept it I just
liked it I don't remember what it was I
remember you did then I remember like
wow not a lot of specials do this and I
kind of liked it you know yeah I think
they wanted me even to not do it but I
just liked that moment I don't remember
why
um
I don't remember why that stayed in I
have no idea but I never mind leaving
that stuff no leave it in I think
because that's the stuff that catches
now that's stuff people talk about is
that crowd work moment yeah I mean I
guess it was a good special but I I
don't watch any of them back once
they're finished
you watch it once while you're editing
and you're done and then I'm like but
that opening I would watch again like
that I feel really that was awesome yeah
stand up is hard for me to watch in
general at this point like I I back in
the day I would watch specials all the
time I feel like Mark still does the
time I try I try to I just I like the
beginning to me I'm like let me see how
they set this special up and what they
do different what room it's in but yeah
it's tough to watch a full hour like big
Jay's got one it just hit a million yeah
and I think big J is hilarious so I
watched most of that one canane has a
new one that's incredible might be his
best work Kyle Kinane check that out so
there's a lot of good comedy but there
might be too many specials there's a
special every 10 seconds I know I don't
watch them because I'm just terrified of
like I I have to know where a joke came
from like people accuse me they said I
took something from Norm it was
something think very similar we had done
our specials apparently but I shot my
special first and I didn't see Norm do
stand up so I knew in my exactly where
this came from like I knew where this
bit came from because I remember when it
started in my real life but if I don't
know where it comes from and it's
something similar I'll drop it like you
know what I mean but I always have to
know so if I watched a lot of stand up I
wouldn't know where it came from but I
have to be able to trace back where a
joke came from I feel similarly and even
if you do come up with it on your own
there's such a thing as parallel
thinking yeah of course I mean that
actually happened to me with a norm bit
that I actually didn't know really yeah
what my mom said to me about Epstein the
worst part is is that he's a Jew and I
didn't know that was a norm Cosby yeah I
didn't know that until I posted and I
think oh I pulled it you know and I hate
when people go like like this is like
for people who are not stamps go you
it's like you took that it's like no
there are thieves and we but we kind of
know who the thieves and concept
Steelers are right like most Comics are
going to step on each other's Dick's
going for a topical joke
happens how many angles are there I mean
especially like that's why a lot of us
will you know Steer clear of you know a
trump thing you're like oh my God how
many [__] angles exactly yeah like I
don't watch people I I like I do a whole
thing about Trump and how his hair is
perfect I'm hoping nobody stops on that
but yeah yeah but you like it you think
the late night guys would uh get on
board with this I watch Colbert then you
watch Seth Meyer then you watch Trevor
Noah then you watch what and it's all
the same Trump stuff you're like come on
you guys are all on at the same time
that's why I mean I happen to love Greg
Gutfeld because he's been he's been good
to me for years and I love the fact that
he's beating all of them only because
it's a different angle it's like not the
same angle coming from it those guys
would switch it up they would do great
again I know exactly and now Fallon's
doing politics you're like you're not
that guy what are you doing you're the
ping-pong guy or the lip sync he's doing
politics yeah a lot of politics up top
don't let it come from the same angle
like Carson would [__] on every you'd
ever really knew where he stood on
because he was just making fun of all of
them that's it right you don't have to
you don't need this uh that's not a
friend of Comedy you [__] oh I agree
we're in the setup when people are
clapping in the setup you've got
yourself a [__] problem and that's
like that's a lot of what it is now it's
it's not even a joke it's like a panda
yeah it's agreeance comedy yeah like I
don't need P I would much rather have
them not agree with me but think the
punch line is so good they laugh like I
like doing pro-trump stuff and pointing
out why I think people who don't like
him what's wrong with you like I like
doing that in New York because I know I
feel them [__] holding back and I
know where I'm going with it and I I
know it's satisfying it's going to be
when they hear it and they just go [__]
it that's funny and they let you know
what I mean like that's comedy I don't
need them to agree with me all right a
reluctant laugh is worth more oh yeah
it's way better way more impressive too
but I did a trump arraignment joke I'm
like you know he might go to jail and
the audience started applauding and I
was like well this is over this is
[__] yeah because I don't I don't need
them to but again they've been kind of
taught that that's a good thing I know
they're all signaling to each other I'm
good are you good yeah we're all good
yeah we're here there's fear yeah but I
I don't it's thank God I don't get it on
the road but I do feel it sometimes in
the city where they're just definitely
in the city yeah but the other [__]
happens on the road like I I I I I
[__] hate I don't care people make
fun of trans people but I hate like the
legislation the anti-gay [__] drives me
[__] crazy so I was mocking it like
in Texas I'm like in here that where the
pro-abortion stuff is probably not going
to do as well like you know where you
are the stuff that's gonna make them go
until they hear the punch line you know
what I mean it's just the total opposite
there that it is here but you know
people who think that they're so free
thinking you're [__] Texans you're as
awful as New Yorkers are I know and vice
versa you're the same [__] people
same people stop thinking you're such
free thinkers dummies because you just
get upset at different things and it's
very take that out I gotta go to Texas
it's very paint by numbers too like this
group's gonna get mad about this this
this topic and this group gonna get mad
about this this topic and they think
they're so different but it's just the
same side of a difference yeah there's
certain parts of my new hour that I feel
pushed back in different parts of the
game yes and I'm like maybe that's good
maybe that's good yeah you're not making
everybody happy right yeah I'll read a
Bill Burr like I'll look at a YouTube
and you read his comments like this
[__] libtard [__] he's lost his head
and the next one's like oh that's all
right piece of [__] and you're like all
right they don't even know where he's at
it is funny when you do a joke and
people both politically come at you and
either think you're on their side like
because like Carlin talked about Free
Speech a lot of conservatives are like
this is the guy right yeah watch the
rest of the app and it's like do you not
know that he would have hated your
stance on gays and abortions and
everything else that's the Brilliance of
Carlin is that literally people from
every thought you know and any political
ideology or sharing his Clips like see
yeah and you're like I I don't know I
mean that but that's when you're that
good an Entertainer and it's that well
written I mean but Carlin would kill for
real everybody he would and he was also
he was he was so good because he was
talking about the people in the room
like those were a lot of his fans but he
wouldn't say you he would just talk
about people and they would laugh and
half of them were Bankers or whatever he
was talking about but it was so they
were able to laugh at themselves yeah I
know and that's like and that's that's
great that you could actually make
someone laugh at themselves that's and
you're doing it without being like you
[__] kill yourself yeah yeah exactly
I went to one of his special tapings in
uh before I did stand up it's like 1989.
I was gonna start comedy and I wound up
going to uh this something the second
one he shot at the State Theater in New
Jersey and you could see me in the
special in like the third row
um and some of the angles it's hard but
I'm so I had like a little turtleneck
and I think a chain
um and it was like 89 so after the show
I wanted to meet him so I walk up and
I'm like hey I'm a comedian I lied
um I'm like can I meet George like he's
not meeting anybody I'm like I'm a
comedian the guy's like all right wow
brought me backstage Asian I got to go
upstairs and meet Carlin
um and he was again he signed my [__]
uh ticket stuff and he was very nice you
know I mean he gave me I forget what
advice he gave me
um I think I asked him something about
his wife being sober but he was nice he
worked the whole room he talked to
everybody but yeah it was uh I was very
happy to meet him that's amazing that
that's like that's the password it works
I'm a comedian yeah but it doesn't work
with everything you know no you know try
that at the [__] Garden to meet the
you know to meet Sabbath or one of the
Knicks I'm a basketball player like get
the [__] out of here I met Carlin too
and he gave me a little razzing and it
was meant the world to me what did he
say about you I went to I took off work
I skipped work and he was at Borders
books on Wall Street signing [__] and I
waited in line like a like an idiot with
all the other people and I was watching
everyone go up to him he's sitting there
at a table and then they're going like I
loved you in Jersey girl I love you and
Bill and Ted I love you in this and I
was like ah so I was like I'm gonna be
the stand-up guy so I go up and I had
brain droppings and all these books I
looked like a real dude leave and I go
up there and I go hey George big fan I
love back in town I love jamming in New
York and I'm dropping all these special
names on him and he's like you're a
comedian I go yeah he goes you sound
like a comedian like oh thanks he goes
you got a real talent for jacking around
I'm still not sure what that means but
I'll take it and we got a photo yeah oh
you did take one oh it's on my wall
framed yeah yeah I got one with him two
years later and I always love Colin for
this when he did tough crowd I got I got
to do it with him and I got to be in the
sketch I wasn't supposed to be in the
sketch it was Carlin and Colin as
priests and then Colin goes at the end
we want you to dress like an altar boy
and break the fourth wall and ask Harlan
to sign a record oh so I interrupted the
sketch and asked him Messiah and he
called me a [__] [__]
like and and the thing he was he goes I
said I love your seven dirty words it
goes yeah that you can't say on
television he goes here's seven more
dirty words you'll never hear on
television welcome to the Jim Norton
show everybody seven more things you'll
ever hear yeah so it was uh that my
tough crowd uh time and Jerry was on
once too I believe yeah I just found
photos I did I did a
a thing it was Seinfeld I was on once
with him but this was in I think 2002
when they were it was eight episodes or
whatever before they knew if it was
going to go the first one was Janine and
I think I forget who else is on that one
had Jerry and somebody else it might
have been Sarah I don't remember yeah
but I did that with that with with
Seinfeld Voss and somebody else and I
was very nervous it's crazy watching
those because there's like a young Kevin
Hart and he's getting trashed and you
know he's the biggest and then there was
a young uh this show would get trashed
oh yeah yeah that's the beauty of it and
then a young Chappelle and you can see
they don't have like this glow of like
super fan uh super stardom yet but it's
so fun to see her I mean they were young
Comics yeah hungry Dave is already
famous though I remember we saw him we
were going to Comedy Central to do some
meeting he was getting on the elevator
talking about this new show he was
working like he was just starting up
with Chappelle show but he was known by
that like Dave was already yeah yeah
yeah people I think they're not even
Professor right right oh man he's so
[__] good Nutty Professor
that scene is hilarious amazing Eddie
Murphy that's an underrated I mean just
that performance is [__] insane by
Eddie Murphy it's like it's insane oh
yeah that was the Hercules all the fat
suits ridiculous yeah he played the mom
the son the brother yeah incredible
Eddie Murphy and Eddie Murphy like when
they would probably yeah I was so yeah
young Chappelle he he'd done a decent he
did that movie with Norm too oh yeah
that's right
what was the movie screwed I think it's
called yeah I think that's it
I think you got it screwed yeah
um you want to start attack I never knew
Norm that well but he started we started
talking after Shane got in trouble and
he was really [__] upset about Shane
he would call Shane yeah he started
dming me he wanted chained to come on
our show but Shane was like waiting to
do his own thing which was smart because
it blew up his body perfect perfect
Playbook yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh Norm
was really bothered by how much [__] he
was getting and that SNL had been
destroyed yeah for him but it worked out
better for shade he's more famous now
than he would have been sure I think
Shane would have would have blown up on
us yeah so I'm sure that's inevitable he
had this thing now where people like
this guy absolutely got [__] and now
we're gonna see what he and he's great
even the times had to admit how funny
you know how [__] hard that must have
been for them to write that article
after they completely agree probably
with him getting fired yeah to have to
admit this guy shouldn't have been fired
I've seen Comics walk up to him I'm not
gonna name names but they're like I [__]
on you sorry and I'm like yeah good for
them for admitting it yeah I mean they
apologize yeah I mean because I I
definitely remember when I was getting
trash and like you know for a joke I
remember people trash
all right well I want a list but you
remember who it was yeah and you'll
never forget nah of course not like 9
11. that's right yeah you never forget
the guys who [__] uh treated you like
[__] I've had good success the first
guys to be nice to be in the city where
Mark Maron Louis and Colin like all
those guys and they were established by
that point but in New York they were the
guys who weren't insecure about me
taking their spots yes like you know a
lot of comics in my you know anytime you
meet guys in your your area they're
worried or they're just like you're the
new guy but those guys didn't give a
[__] they knew I wasn't going to do
anything to hurt what they were doing
I've seen that Trend the funny guys are
never the meanest it's always the you
know shaky kind of marginal guys will
try to sabotage you because they deep
down even if they're arrogant and
narcissistic they know that they're kind
of frauds those guys knew that they
weren't like you know Collins no one's
taking Colin or Louise or [__] Marc
maron's spot Marin I feel like was
underrated back then was he was he not I
feel like I mean Lou I feel like Louie
probably got more shine uh Colin
obviously had the TV show but Marin I
feel like I remember he told me when
she's like I did like 37 Conan yeah I
couldn't sell a [__] ticket on the
road that's right yeah I remember being
kicked off the radio being and being in
Florida listening to mark on
um it was uh I think it was called
morning's Edition like morning sedition
when he had like the air America show
and I was so jealous but back then
people didn't the podcast blew him up
obviously right right um and he's a good
actor so he does like he is but he's a
great interviewer like he's a good
talker yeah he's comfortable he can keep
it going for two hours like so that
podcast he used to do that in our studio
he when when that started he would come
into serious and like use an Opie and
Anthony Studio like or Production Studio
to do his podcast in I didn't know that
no but I'm not saying it was our doing
it was just one of the places he would
he would tape but yeah back then people
didn't really comedians respected him
though Comics always respected Mark he
was like among us he was like he had a
show called never mind the buzz [__]
which I did with Coolio and uh the woman
who sang in Berlin in take my breath
away it was a very bizarre [__] uh
very bizarre panel a lot of range and
you uh I heard your interview with him
and he he had a lot of respect for you
it was a good okay oh I don't remember
it I mean it was on it was uh on his uh
he's always been very cool to me like I
love Mark I know a lot of guys didn't
they thought he was aloof or whatever
but um it's because he was kind of you
always knew where you stood with him
like he was kind of again emotionally
honest right right he's a blunt guy but
it's weird there's always gonna be heads
bumping like I remember listening to
some radio show where Geraldo and
Patrice Patrice like I hated you for a
while and now we're cool but I if I saw
you I wanted to fight you and Gerald was
like really I didn't even know that he's
like oh yeah I hated you and you're like
man no matter what time or what level
you're at there's always some beef yeah
there's always a guy that reads
something wrong or it's jealousy or
whatever the fight that you just like uh
I don't for these people I just don't
like and sometimes I don't know why I
don't like them yeah I love Rosebud
because like there was somebody she
didn't like and there's a bunch of us
just sitting there and when the person
likes she's like I don't [__] like
him and I'm like the fact that she said
it to all like like she didn't care if
any of us right I really like that she's
very blunt yeah we had her on she's
great yeah she is she's to the point
there's something yeah there's something
about having beef though when you get to
a certain age where you're like this is
[__] I know what are we doing I don't
yeah I I had a weird thing with a guy
and I just texted him I was like what
are we doing and it was kind of like we
kind of squashed as a comedian yeah but
I was like what are we doing and it was
it's fine now but you get to an age
where you're like I don't want a [__]
dread running into a adult I know this
is so stupid so stupid we're doing like
this is such a fun [__] gig like
there's enough problems without worrying
about bumping into another car it's just
annoying I don't want to worry about
[__] that isn't new jokes yes you know I
don't want to worry about [__] that
isn't you know the job and then you
think about you're like oh this is going
to take up a part of you know any part
of my mind for tonight I don't want to
deal with it I completely agree yeah do
you avoid eye contact do you not say
hello
like I found out there was a guy within
the last two years a year somebody told
me like yeah he was [__] on your set
while you were on and I really want to
call him out on it
um like like what do you [__] you
think you're a brilliant joke writer you
idiot
um but I I'm like ah it was told to me
kind of in confidence and I'm like and
what are you gonna gain by confronting
yeah I apologize I mean how bad was it
not terrible but like misreading
the point I was making like I hate when
and like and it was a seller set it was
yeah it's like also a workout set and
you've earned you've earned enough
respect to be like let them [__] let
me find let him find somebody who didn't
like the angle I was taking because I
don't double down on either side I think
he was one of those people that thinks
that if you loathe each side that you're
afraid to take a stand uh which you know
it's just I would love to have had that
chat with him uh yeah but who cares I'm
afraid to take a step I'm trying to be
funny what was this stand [__] exactly
and it wasn't even that it really wasn't
that it was just it was annoying his
misinterpretation of it and the fact
that he said it to another comic uh and
the other comic told me which I loved
yeah but I've also never you're never a
comic who have been like this dude's
scared to say something
it's true no but it was more like or
maybe he thought it was hey
um yeah I hate when guys like like I
don't know I I think that he thought
that I was like playing both sides of it
but because I I was worried about and
it's like no I just don't think you're
[__] Hive mentality is brave dummy
like I I we Define it differently yes
but I would love to have had that
argument with him um yeah but it just he
didn't say it to me so I can't betray
somebody else's
you know what I mean I hear you okay I
bet I know who it is after the show yeah
um anything you want to plug just um
when does this air probably this weekend
now right I guess Sunday okay uh do you
hate when you're taping with somebody
and they're like look I gotta is this
gonna be out by seven tonight
uh yeah I got a bunch of uh gigs coming
up I'm in Cleveland 21st 22nd I have uh
what do I have uh hilarities I got oh
best club correct isn't it great that's
like my favorite Nick is the [__]
coolest I've only done it once oh it's
great that's like top five for me I love
it Bethlehem PA the uh 19th of uh May
Wellmont Theater in Jersey the 20th and
I'm on Bert's tour 17th to 18th and I'm
doing of June I'm in Rogan's Club in
July oh nice I don't think that's on
sale yet I'm sure if Joe tweets it'll it
will help yeah I hope so yeah that's I'm
finally going back out on the road I was
just like uninspired for a long time
thank you guys for having me I love both
you guys you guys are so inspirational
you're doing seriously the way you guys
are blown up just you're using your
material like if you're not you're not
working like you're putting great jokes
out and you're forcing people to go this
guy is funny and coming see I love what
you guys are both doing honestly we
write a lot because the guys like you
Louis Colin you know a tail like the the
guard in New York that's like you know
the New York Legends so yeah we write
jokes you know thank you I will I will
say thank you very much for that as much
as people will object to you putting me
in that category with those guys
that'll be your number one comment like
really yeah Colin yeah but this guy I
I've exhausted all my cities so I'm
going to weird towns I'm going to my
Bozeman Montana I'm going to Great Falls
Montana Dayton then uh then it's off to
Australia going down under so come to
Sydney Melbourne Brisbane Auckland New
Zealand holy [__] damn it's gonna be
nuts say hello markdown montgomery.com
San Diego Sacramento uh Columbus
Cincinnati Indianapolis tickets low as
[__] Kalamazoo in a 1500 seater for some
reason help me the [__] out uh
Perrysburg Bethlehem Wilmington Delaware
also could use a bump there so uh
Baltimore Philly Hampton Beach Portland
Maine Connecticut Richmond Olive yeah
you see it yo samrail.com shows uh
Denver Nashville San Antonio Houston see
you on the road wait what is that go
back down a little bit there's a
misprint I've never seen that no go down
what is it Late Show added
never seen that on my website
there you go folks you're here first
follow Jim's team on the road one of the
best drink Bodega cat whiskey guys
Bodega catwhiskey.com we here it's very
close to being legal in New York nice
fingers fingers crossed Hallelujah
finally so yeah get a bottle go gay
check out Jim and we'll see you in hell
yep
[Music]
dangerous
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]